what are the first steps in writing a
crime drama
to write a crime drama you first need to
know how story works really well because
crime dramas are left brain right brain
you have to know exactly The Logical
um
plot right your plot and your Trails of
evidence have to make sense not just for
your hero your investigator but also for
your criminal your criminal definitely
needs his or her own very structured
story but then there's the whole other
emotional element relational element to
the story that you need
to know how to tell well because that's
the thing that keeps that keeps is the
page Turner that's the thing that keeps
you coming back after the commercials or
binge the next
episode is that that underlying the
humanity behind all of it right
that your investigators need and even
um I think we've come a long way when I
look at like TV from the 80s and 90s to
now even criminals have
been it's never black and white like
white right it's it's like that you we
used to be able to get away with like
the bad guy and he's sort of this
stereotypic thing but it's we are not
bad guys are not black and white
um criminals are not Black and White in
real life there's layers and layers to
why they got to where they did and so uh
those two things on on layering those
for your protagonist and your criminal
are the for me the foundations like
that's where you have to start you have
to know how to tell story really well
and then how to really think through
these two major
chess pieces
what should happen the first 10 pages
of a crime Thriller drama what's crucial
kind of the same is really any story
setup
um you're setting things up you're
setting up your crime you typically not
you're because you're introducing oh
we're this is a crime Jonah we're going
to tell you about a crime that happened
so you're setting up your crime your
criminal World your criminal you're
setting up your investigator and his or
her world and what that looks like
sometimes investigators are
professionals sometimes they're not what
is sometimes they're this is their job
and so that innately gives them a motive
for having to investigate something a
lot of times they're not they're maybe
reluctant heroes or they get thrown into
a situation where they're sort of forced
to investigate something and then you
know become more obsessed about it but
that's it's really kind of yeah the
first 10 pages it's really the same as
setting up any story
um your main
your main characters and your world and
the tone what kind of ride we're going
to go on the if you would look at the
pilot of Pushing Daisies which is very
fun right very quirky fun kind of Crime
Story versus uh you know Dexter pilot
it's the Tone's very different right so
you're setting that up too right away
you said to start your story in the
middle of things come in late leave
early why is that in media raised just
yeah start in the middle of things it's
I mean really I think for any story you
want to do this but I think it's really
important for this type of story because
you are constantly trying to build
tension and suspense and you want to
come in late and leave early so that
helps you build that that pacing that
tension you don't want extra
really I'm obviously like in any script
there's not room for extraneous right
you only want what's on the page or on
screen to be there and nothing else it I
think it's like tenfold for crime
stories
if you're especially if the tone is to
is less relationship relational less
comedic and more about the action The
Thrill The Adventure the suspense the
tension because you're really you don't
want to leave any room you want to just
keep it super tight and keep us on that
ride you know fast
okay so with if we could use an example
so let's say I'm trying to think of the
beginning of sharp objects but we're not
necessarily seeing all the mundane right
of her life we're speeding right right I
mean yes exactly um you're only going to
see and honestly it's a great
um
that's a great way of putting it because
you really are trying to build for your
protagonist you're really trying to
build in the motive right what is
driving them personally let's just take
professionally off the table because
um especially for like detectives like
that is their job so the motive there's
a different kind of motive because the
motive is like that's your job here's
your case you know oh that's today's job
um but it's like sharper objects she
doesn't have to take this
um and even like Breaking Bad in the
pilot the first 10 minutes we're really
seeing what Walter White's or right in
the middle of the abyss of his life at
this moment when he's just at its lowest
of his low like he's found out he's
gonna die and he's he's not respected at
school he's not respected outside of
school so we're seeing that setup of
that motive of why he's gonna delve into
the world of crime criminal activity so
we're setting it up really fast and in
multiple
little scenes
so I think
that's a really because we don't it's
and he's he's definitely more of the
Caper kind of so it's a little bit
different than a traditional detective
kind of crime story but even with
the traditional detectives you're seeing
right away
um they're getting launched into this
crime right and they have to go on the
scene and right away they're trying to
evaluate everything they're right in the
middle of this chaos somebody's just
been murdered and this is a chaotic
world and what do we know we have to
Quick figure out what we know so you're
given you're you're given as an audience
and them as a protagonists are given
just the pieces they need at that moment
to propel them to the next scene and
then the next scene in the next scene
one of the things that's tempting
for people who are newer in writing this
genre and I'm just as I was guilty of
this is just wanting to throw all the
evidence up front you know within that
first 10 or 20 Pages we don't need that
we don't we shouldn't have that it's
it's a rabbit Trail and so we're going
to lay carrots all the way through to
the very end so you're only giving your
Your Heroes exactly what they need in
the moment to just get to the next step
to figure out the next step and then the
next step and then the next step and of
course obstacles are going to get thrown
in their way and
bounce them around so
so we don't want to make it too easy for
the reader or the viewer to solve and at
times maybe throw them off keep them
guessing yeah I
definitely you don't want it to be easy
for your hero I always think about I
don't want it to be easy for my hero
because that makes that person kind of
boring and not very good at his job or
her job and it makes them not very human
so they may do things they may make
mistakes
there's definitely I always say like you
definitely want rabbit trails that don't
pan out they find a piece of evidence
and it doesn't pan out they talk to a
witness that they think oh my goodness I
just solved the case or this is it we
got what we need and it doesn't work out
so you definitely want that for for your
hero also for your
also of course for your audience yeah
yeah you want to take them on the ride